I think most Americans are pretty
independent-minded most Americans have
very libertarian or classical liberal
tendencies and so I think they can
relate to my frustrations working within
the party system and why I'd want to
leave that that system when Michigan
representative Justin Amash declared his
independence from the Republican Party
on July 4th he instantly became one of
the most controversial politicians in
America Donald Trump immediately took to
Twitter to denounce Amash calling him a
total loser and one of the dumbest and
most disloyal members of Congress but
whether you agree with the five term
congressman's choice to leave the
Republican Party he's anything but dumb
and unprincipled Amash has been the most
consistently libertarian member of
Congress since taking office in 2011
he's repeatedly voted to reduce the size
and spending of the federal government
to stop mass surveillance of American
citizens and to end overseas wars he
believes lack constitutional
authorization I spoke with Amash the son
of middle-eastern immigrants at Freedom
Fest the annual gathering of
libertarians in las vegas we talked
about what it feels like to be an
independent why he won't be joining
Alexandria kzo cortezes social justice
squad anytime soon whether he thinks
Donald Trump did this is actually racist
if he's going to run for president as a
libertarian and why he believes we need
to talk more about love in national
politics
[Applause]
Justin Amash thanks for talking reason
thanks so much now what's it feel like
to be independent now it feels good I'm
happy I have better relationships with a
lot of my colleagues frankly because
there's not the same pressure to fall in
line with a party and I've been thinking
about this for years and really have
found myself unhappy a lot of the time
in Congress because you feel like you're
spinning your wheels you're trying to
make things work you're trying to
improve the system and you find that
you're going nowhere and my colleagues
who are also trying are also going
nowhere so it's you know it's a it's a
relief and it's it's nice to be happy
and free and representing my concessions
do you feel like you can speak I mean
you you can speak more freely so you're
not contorting yourself yeah you know as
much as people think well Justin's
already very independent he was an
independent Republican he spoke his mind
and I got that from a lot of my family
members too and others hey you know if
you stay a Republican you can still
speak your mind and do whatever you you
like and I think a lot of people don't
realize the amount of pressure we face
every day to fall in line with the party
so even those of us who are very
independent are facing pressure from our
friends and colleagues and it's it's
like you know pressure from essentially
friends you know like do you want to
upset you the people you work with every
day you have to see them every day you
go into work you are at meetings
together do you really want to upset
them day after day and and that that
takes a toll on people and my colleagues
you know they don't want to be
independent they want to just keep doing
the same thing and and they can survive
in the system but it's not my kind of
thing
obviously the the Muller report and kind
of your reading of that and your
attitude towards Trump was part of this
process but other things what was the
big split ultimately between the GOP
vision of America and your vision of
America where you're like okay I'm done
here well it's not really the molar
report or even Donald Trump I think
Donald Trump is a symptom of the problem
and I've been thinking about becoming an
independent for quite a while I've
talked about it in previous sessions of
Congress previous terms with my
colleagues I've talked to my family
about it and friends about it and it's
just that we've gotten to the point
where finally I came to the conclusion
that this was not going to turn around
for the party or for the two-party
system I mean I want to be clear I'm
obviously very familiar with the
Republican Party and how it works but
Democrats have the same problems
internally and the system itself is
driving us toward what I call this this
partisan death spiral where I don't
think we can escape from it and everyone
is just angry all the time and has such
contempt for everyone else and do you
see any other members following you and
becoming independent well I hear from
colleagues every day in fact after I
became independent I went back to work
the next week and I had several
colleagues come up to me and ask me
about the logistics of it any times we
really did not know but they asked me
that about the logistics of it and and
how you might go about doing it and they
they felt this way for a long time too
that they want to become independent I
don't know whether any of them will ever
do it but I've talked to them and I've
made the point that there needs to be a
revolution in politics one person doing
it great I can go out and I can educate
people and talk about the problems of
the two-party system but if we had three
or four or twelve or two dozen people
doing it
then you have a revolution within the
system and then you can start to really
change things in a major way
so what again what is it about the GOP
right now that you're just like I'd
rather be outside the party than inside
what is is you know what are the key
issues well there's there are no
principles other than sticking with the
leader of the party so you know we
talked about limited government economic
freedom and individual liberty on the
campaign trail but when you go to
Congress none of that is a concern I
mean nobody follows the Constitution or
cares about the Constitution people talk
about spending you know they say oh
we're spending too much money but then
they've keep voting for more spending so
the Republican Party is not living up to
the ideals it talks about there they
talk about FISA for example in the
context of the Russia situation but
then they'll vote for Pfizer
reauthorization and the president will
sign it into law so the president is
using the same power that he's decrying
all the time and that that his
supporters that are crying so I think
that it's become very much wrapped up
around a personality and it used to be
wrapped up around other leaders it might
be the Speaker of the House of he's a
Republican or someone else but it gets
wrapped up around a few figures who
really control the whole system and and
it's true on the Republican side and the
Democratic side
what should Nancy Pelosi be doing
differently as Speaker she should be
opening up the process and this is
something I said when Ryan was the
speaker and when Boehner was the speaker
and the most shocking thing that I've
discovered his Boehner might have been
the best speaker that I've served under
so and I'm sure somewhere he's high and
drunk and he's like oh maybe it wasn't
so bad you know my friend Thomas Massie
so frequently on plane ride both of them
and I said hey tell him that we want him
back as much as I had problems with John
Boehner and and do have serious problems
and and I don't think he ran it in a
very open way he's been better than what
we've seen from Ryan or from Pelosi they
have to open up the process what I've
said many times is the legislative
process is supposed to be a process of
discovery we're spoiling we're supposed
to discover the will of the people
through the process instead they are
deciding the outcomes ahead of time a
few people get together the Speaker of
the House the Senate Majority Leader the
President of the United States they get
together they decide what outcome do
they want and then they go and try to
you know twist arms and try to get get
the votes they need and that's not the
process that the founders designed it's
closely a particularly effective speaker
I mean independent of your concerns or
the content that she's pushing but I'm
she really good at what she does
it depends on what you mean by effective
I think that she does have a lot of
control over her side I don't know that
that's a good thing that's but some
people might view that as effective that
she's she's able to control the diverse
body of people but as I said I don't
think that's the way Congress is
supposed to work she's supposed to look
out for the institution first not just
her political power and and perpetuating
that power do
have a speaker historically who you
think was the best speaker I know I I'm
too young to think about like a
millennial or something so yeah screw
history right what about you remember
like back to Gingrich and that oh god
and and I think he is one of the people
who actually started this process of
really centralizing power I suspect that
he is not getting as much credit as he
would want but he's really when politics
kind of started to become what they have
begin yeah I think so I think that the
system we have today the the way the
speaker works today is very much in the
mold of Newt Gingrich and and he seems
to have moved us more strongly in that
direction than previous speakers do you
see yourself particularly now that
you're an independent will you be
working with either the freedom caucus
which you've resigned from but also with
like Alexandria okay so Cortes and her
squad I mean are you going to become the
first male member of the Spice Girls or
squad okay but no but is there is there
room there to work with somebody like a
sa there's room to work with everyone so
I've always held that view that I should
be able to work with every single person
in Congress regardless of their
political philosophy or political party
you're not going to agree with everyone
on everything obviously I don't agree
with you know my closest colleagues on
everything Thomas Massie and I could
have big disagreements on some issues
we're not voting a like on every single
issue so you know I look at where we
have common ground and you know if a OC
has 20% common ground with me on
something I'm gonna work with her on
that issue and and similarly with the
freedom caucus
maybe I'll agree with 50 or 60 percent
of what they're doing and we'll work on
those things together do you worry about
the the rise of so-called democratic
socialists and and kind of what AOC and
her squad represent I mean it's it's a
pretty frontal attack on the things that
you care about do you think they're
growing in power or is this kind of
their their own kind of wilderness beast
you know
I think that they have some influence
and I think they are effective at
getting their message out there I would
I would say that they are really a
reaction to Donald Trump and for
Republicans who are worried about
socialism and worried about big
government and there are still a few
Republicans who are worried about big
government I think that the rise of
Donald Trump has really helped lift
these types of members of Congress out
the ones who are pushing for socialism
if you're worried about socialism then
you have to worry about the reaction
that the general public has the Donald
Trump because I think when they see the
kinds of things he's saying and when he
gets them so angry when he creates such
a level of discord in contempt and I'm
not saying the other side is pure right
you know they they do lots of things at
times to rile people up and and be nasty
to other people as well but Donald Trump
is the President of the United States
he's at the top
he shouldn't be punching down he should
be setting an example for everyone and
when he doesn't set the right example I
think you shouldn't be surprised that
you're going to have some kind of
socialist pushback and that people might
turn to things like socialism the other
thing I would say is if you create an
environment of contempt like the
president is at least facilitating you
know I'm not gonna say he started it but
but he's definitely putting fuel into
the fire if you have that environment of
contempt Liberty cannot survive in that
environment Liberty requires a level of
trust and societal cohesion where people
are willing to work with each other and
respect each other and love each other
if you have a society where everyone's
angry they're definitely going to turn
to government as the child of immigrants
had had a you were how did you feel when
Trump said to you know various members
of Congress mistakenly thinking they
were immigrants themselves that they
should get back to their own to their
own country I mean how did you as I said
I think that's racist I think it's
offensive to a lot of people I'm a
person who faces that kind of
discrimination on social media for sure
day after day I have so many examples of
that being told to go back to your
country or go back where you came from
and I think that there are many people
out there including many of my
colleagues so I talked to this talk
about this issue to to them they don't
relate to it you know they haven't
experienced that in the same way so they
don't quite understand it and and those
of us who come from families where we've
had recent immigrants in the family like
my parents are immigrants I think we
experienced it a lot more and we we can
see that it's intended as a type of
racial slur you know you're kind aren't
welcome here could you talk a little bit
more about your vision of America I mean
it generally you oftentimes you talk a
lot about how you how Congress should
work etc but what is what's your big
picture for America that proceeds from
your beliefs and limited government well
my my big picture is in America where
people care about each other where they
respect each other where they trust each
other you're always going to have you
know bad apples in the system you're
going to have people who commit crimes
you're going to have people who are
hostile but as a general matter I think
what separates America from a lot of
other countries at least historically is
that the people tend to get along pretty
well we tend to trust each other and and
I noticed this growing up you know I
took a few trips when I was younger went
to Europe for example with my family and
on a school trip and you'd notice
differences in the culture where there
was a lot of distrust people did not
feel the same sense of cohesion and in
America look who we have a place where
we will have a bookstore and the books
will be outside of the store you know
they trust no one's gonna walk by and
and snatch one of the books and and take
it home and I think that stems from our
culture of Liberty and and when you are
you know self-reliant when you when you
demand personal responsibility in your
life you tend to trust each other
more actually when you put so much power
in governments hands you tend to become
distrustful of people do you feel do you
feel then there's a kind of broader
libertarian culture in America that is
related I mean it's the place we get
along because things are voluntary or
people are only showing up because I
want to I think that just our culture
from the very beginning from our
foundation was very much a classical
liberal trusting sort of culture where
people just work together in communities
there was very much of a community
sentiment and worked together to get
things done on a voluntary basis you
know maybe it stemmed from you know our
opposition to the throne at the very
beginning and and just the sense of
community hey we don't have a king
ruling over us we have to work together
the people you've mentioned that you
know we're in a period and you know
certainly Donald Trump reflects us and
helps further it but of animosity anger
what not what what can be done to kind
of start pulling that back and
recreating the the world that you're
talking about I think it requires a lot
of small steps and it requires different
people to do different things depending
on what their position and life is I you
know I'm in a position where I'm a
member of Congress I have a lot of
influence I feel the need to go out
there and use that that influence that I
have to spread the message of love
spread the message of Liberty talk about
working together and respecting each
other and how a lot of our problems can
be solved voluntarily we don't need
government to control everything and
decide everything for us and then when
we talk about government we can also
talk about different levels of
government that do things you know a lot
of people say well either government
will do it or the private sector and I
like to point out look there are
different levels of government to some
things might happen at the federal level
some things might happen at the state
level some things might happen locally
some things might happen in your family
there all sorts of government but when
you get closer to home it's it's like a
more like a private action and so
recasting it that way getting people to
understand what creates a you know a
smoothly operating society is important
to me what how are your constituents
responded are they happy with you did
they feel cheated because they elected
you as a Republican what what kind of
feedback have you been getting it's been
overwhelmingly positive now there are
definitely people who are upset they're
definitely people who are diehard Trump
supporters or very much you know
diehard party loyalists who who don't
like it but overall the reception has
been very positive and I think most
Americans are pretty independent minded
most Americans have very libertarian or
classical liberal tendencies and so I
think they can relate to my frustrations
working within the party system and why
I'd want to leave that that system
did you talk directly with your
constituents about this beforehand or
how did you but how did you manage that
well communication the important thing
to know about my district is that for
years I've been a very
independent-minded congressman people
know that I don't tell the party line
people know that when I run for office
I'm running as an independent principled
person I tell them the set of principles
I'm running on and they know that I'm
going to follow those principles even if
it means going against my party so
nobody's surprised by that kind of thing
and I think just all the interactions
I've had over the years I've held many
town halls I've been very open with the
community about where I stand and I've
listened to their concerns it was pretty
obvious to me that this is a community
that will be supportive of this kind of
thing do you worry about being primaried
and you know I've seen some early polls
showing that you you know you are gonna
have a real tough pre-election battle
yeah so I'm running as an independent so
I won't be involved in the primary but I
was never really worried about the
primary I mean if I'd stayed as a
Republican I would have won that primary
I think you have a bunch of people
running who are going to run on the pro
Trump banner and you have one person
who's saying I'm gonna stand up for the
Constitution I'm gonna stand up for the
people I represent I think when you
break it down that way it's easy to see
how I come out on top what about
President
you've talked in the past about possibly
running for president on the lp
libertarian party whatever what goes
into that calculation and where where
are you on that now well I think what
goes into the calculation is deciding
and thinking about where I can use my
skills and my influence best you know I
believe very strongly that we need
independent minded members of Congress I
feel strongly about representing my
community I love my community I love
representing my community so if I can be
most effective in that role that's what
I'll do but I also think about you know
other roles and that's why when people
ask me would you rule this out or rule
that out I don't tend to rule things out
that way it doesn't mean that I'm at a
stage where I'm gonna say yeah I'm gonna
do this for sure or I'm you know even 50
percent there but I do like to at least
consider these things
I'm stay open-minded about them and
think about how I can be most effective
and if I feel I can be effective on the
national stage spreading the message of
Liberty and the message of respect and
love then that's what I do do you have a
campaign slogan yep
you're obviously running so it's a devil
but do you have that you know I'm not
obviously ready okay all right well I
think we'll leave it there thanks so
much for talking about the reason thanks
so much now for reason I'm Nicholas
[Music]